Amy Schumer just demanded up a big hike
in her 11 million dollar fee for her
Netflix special after learned that Chris
Rock and Dave Chappelle earned more and
by the way they did it so that's if no
no silent that's what brings us to well
this week's segment this week but my
vagina you knew that was coming so
here's the thing if you look at Amy
Schumer the the the reason for demanding
higher pay her plea basically amounts to
now she wants the same payroll payment
of Chappelle or Chris Rock because they
think it's unfair ziz a blow to gender
equality as written about it variety and
you know I guess it's hard to find
people to pay you to perform after the
stigma with blackfish so Amy Schumer is
in compares a thing it doesn't stand up
in this is a perfect microcosm for the
77 cents on the dollar myth the feminism
equal pay myth because I don't think you
could have a more clear-cut example of
someone undeserving
so let's see why or why might she make
less than Chris Rock and then you you
comment let me know what you think as to
whether this is fair or not and by the
way I used to defend Amy Schumer I think
I think she can be funny so Chris Rock
returned from an eight-year hiatus Yeah
right away so there's a lot there's a
lot of anticipation guys one for Emmy
Awards three Grammy Awards total film
gross of 3.3 billion dollars and I know
you think that's nothing all films make
billions of dollars notice no Amy
Schumer total about 200 million so
that's actually about 1/16 of what Chris
Rock brought in and he also had a hit
show Everybody Hates Chris yeah okay so
that's why Amy Schumer might make less
than Chris Rock what about Dave
Chappelle it's at some point you've
gotta go okay there's a pattern Johan
Dave Chappelle was ranked top 10 by
Rolling Stone and comedians of all time
now he also he was gone for I think
eight years after walking away from one
of the most lucrative deals if you
remember this yeah at Comedy Central it
was fifty million dollar thing
saying yeah and walked away from it and
he sort of has become a hermit like any
video of Dave Chappelle that's out there
right now if your YouTube tons of
millions of times blown hey it's it's
like a spotted owl yeah they want to see
the guy
it's a sighting people want to see him
so now why did they offer him so much
money Comedy Central well this is also
important because his ratings were
incredible and in contrast to a lot of
other shows he was able to actually grow
his audience over time often you hit a
crest yeah he was building it so they
wanted him to stay well over three
million viewers yeah at Comedy Central
compare that with Amy Schumer her
ratings only got worse over time as a
matter of fact in season four it went
down to four hundred ninety one thousand
same day viewers same day viewers by the
way that includes any reruns for inside
Amy Schumer moving on in case you need
more his special on Netflix has gotten
really good reviews well they're do them
actually outside of some angry social
justice warriors over the [ __ ] jokes
consider us not amongst them
in contrast Amy Schumer's Netflix
especially I get comedies subjective but
hers was so bad Netflix had to change
its rating system allegedly it was
coincidence that she complained about
the rating system thumbs up next flick
should have done the renegotiation you
ever tried a thumbs down Amy Schumer's
Netflix special it's like a Florida
voting booth
so let's disregard Netflix even after
Netflix for I am a universally panned by
critics the IMDB score is I think 3 out
of 10 only 7 percent of people on Rotten
Tomatoes liked it so wow this is
comparing you compare the show ratings
you compare the box-office gross it's
completely uncomfortable and then you
compare the actual Netflix specials that
are there and by the way Dave Chappelle
also signed a contract for several
special yeah after coming out for 8
years people want to see him people are
anticipating it it sounds to me like
maybe me shimmer should be worrying
about the 77 laughs / Chappelle's 103 no
that's actually yes I'm only getting 77
laughs on the dollar me 7 that's
generous
and so with all of us put together on
what merit do we think what marriage is
Amy Schumer think she deserves more
dough mm-hmm what else could there be
something else at play that she thinks
hmm what could she possibly conclude
what y'all know getting jr. from 9 years
ago no that's probably 15 years ago a
long w yeah yeah so here's something
else but I just find funny the fact is
that black men on average make 89
percent what white women make now it was
really yeah it's at all I will admit
this right now it's a totally unfair
statistic yes exactly what feminists do
just compare the mean salary perfect
it's not at all fair but considering it
that I mean live by the phony stat died
by the funny style since you say 77
cents in the dollar black men make an
average 89 percent what a white woman
man so you have to ask yourself one
thing if Chappelle and Chris Rock case
you didn't know both black men are
making that much more it's an Amy
Schumer a white woman then she must be
really bad hey if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you're not aware of it
now there's no way you're learning the
Internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to Lata
with credit calm slash mug Club members
of your student military or veteran
internet promo code it's less than $6 a
month and you get daily content no more
clips Plus this hand at smug oh I just
when I feel it I got a chill like on the
inside